now i do admit that i have a lot of
videos on things that you have to avoid
because they're bad for you but today
i'm going to talk about an addiction i'm
sorry um a drink that you won't have to
avoid and i will be the first to admit
that i am completely and utterly
addicted to coffee and its benefits and
there's one thing in coffee called
chlorogenic acid it's in other foods as
well but it's definitely in coffee if
you drink green coffee you will have
more of this chemical and i have done
other videos on the benefits of coffee
adding butter and mct oil to your coffee
to help you fast longer but there's some
interesting research on coffee
in that it can help decrease the risk
for metabolic syndrome
it gives you neural protection for your
brain
cardiovascular protection and even
studies that show that it can be
anti-carcinogenic
coffee definitely can suppress your
appetite which is good to do in the
morning if you're fasting and also this
compound right here connect to help
reduce inflammation
and there's a significant amount of
magnesium in coffee as well as certain
vitamins specifically b3
and b2 now of course these benefits are
not going to occur if you're drinking
pots of coffee like i used to drink in
college so i'm talking about a very
moderate or small amount of coffee
personally i recommend only drinking one
cup of coffee in the early morning but
we have this liver here and the liver
actually does a lot of things one thing
it does is it makes
bile okay so the bile is produced by the
liver drains down these little tubes
right here and gets stored in the
gallbladder and so a lot of people have
the question is coffee going to
aggravate my gallbladder or create
kidney stones or
contribute to my fatty liver well
actually it does the opposite it will
help to thin the bile it can help to
decrease the risk for gall stones
because gallstones come from
a condition where you have this super
concentrated cholesterol that turns into
crystals
then forms gallstones but it's not the
cholesterol that makes the stone it's
the lack of bile salts that allow the
concentration to occur so really
gallstones occur because you are
deficient in bile well it just so
happens that coffee can help produce
more bile and thin the bile and prevent
these cholesterol crystals from
occurring now if you have gallstones i
would highly recommend you also start
taking
like purified bile salts to help you
with this process but just you know
coffee can help prevent gallstones and
as far as the liver goes
coffee is hepatoprotective so these
phytonutrients in the coffee can
actually protect the liver from harmful
things
the other thing that's really cool about
coffee is it can increase fatty acid
oxidation that basically means it can
help break down
fat from your liver especially if you
have a fatty liver and it does this
indirectly through the microbiome which
is actually quite fascinating so coffee
apparently helps your friendly bacteria
it also helps stimulate this hormone
that will help contract the gallbladder
the gallbladder is there to concentrate
the bile so when you eat it contracts
and then that bile then can mix with the
food and help you extract fat soluble
nutrients well if your gallbladder is
sluggish for whatever reason drinking
coffee can help stimulate the
gallbladder so you have this contraction
in this release of the bile and one
reason why i'm doing this video is
because i'm i'm focusing on this area
right here making you very aware of this
area
in your body because this is an area of
a lot of problem for so many people that
they don't have any idea
that this is the root problem and i'm
talking about
bile sludge the bile should normally be
thin and flowing many times it thickens
and then the cholesterol starts building
up in here and it backs up into the
liver and the pain that you'll feel or
the discomfort or the tightness will be
right up through here in your right
shoulder blade right through here and
through the back right through here
through the rhomboid it can go right
through the head through here it can
literally create tension and pull these
vertebra out and pinch a nerve that goes
down your right side now on that note if
you haven't seen my video on the
relationship between the gallbladder and
the right shoulder i'm going to put that
video up right here check it out
you